We have some amazing news for you!
Don’t Memorise is awarded the diamond play button!
Sorry, that’s fake news!
We go through news on various platforms everyday,
be it in digital or printed formats.
But, there’s this one question that always ponders in our minds.
Why is News called so?
Does it mean “North, East, West and South” ?
Or “Notable events, Weather and Sports” ?
We’ve heard this many times, but is 'NEWS' really an acronym?
Let's find out.
The answer may sound quite silly.
'News' just means 'new things'.
But then why do most of us think that News is an acronym?
Because back in time
"News” was not really a word in the English language.
'News' is derived from the Adjective 'New'.
And in the English language,
we know that Adjectives cannot be plural.
Consider the example, Amazing video.
Can you tell me the plural of Amazing?
It’s definitely not Amazings.
So how did the word 'News' surface?
This leap from the word ‘New'
to ‘News' is believed to be influenced by Old French.
In French, 'New' means 'Nouveau'.
But in the French language,
there's also a plural form of 'Nouveau' called 'Nouvelles',
from which the word 'News' was derived.
So now we know why 'News' is called so!
It's officially designated as a word which represents “new things''.
But how does any random set of letters get designated as a word?
Let’s say, we came up with a random set of letters
Kyu Box which according to us represents Curiosity.
So can this word get into the Dictionary?
Well, there are a few people called Lexicographers
who are assigned this task of making this decision!
But can Lexicographers themselves finalize
a particular word and include it in the dictionary?
No, its not that easy!
This new set of random letters needs to
undergo various tests and also pass with flying colours.
And what are these tests?
Curious?
We took the first step with you,
but Kyu Box is for you to explore.
Let us know your findings in the comment section.
I have something interesting to share.
We will be airing one bonus Qpisode at the end of the first season.
And guess what?
We will be answering a question that you have for us.
Ask us your question in the comment section below,
and we will answer it in that Qpisode
I look forward to your questions!